[Music]
every month i come here and i hear the
same thing
social emotional health if you truly
mean that
you would end the mask requirement
tonight
this is not march 2020 anymore and it's
time
take these masks off of my child
that georgia mother is going viral after
taking a stand for students and her
child and demanding her county
her county school board removed their
mask mandate this is in gwinnett county
down in georgia
our next guest has been pressing the cdc
for answers on why they are still
requiring children as young as
two to wear masks here now is utah
senator
mike lee good morning to you senator
good morning you can hear the
ladies frustration she stood up there
and she said my child and other children
in our district
are begging parents to come to these
school board meetings tell them please
beg for them these kids don't want to
wear masks at school and then tell us
about the letter that you sent
yeah recently i sent a letter to dr
rochelle
wolenski director of the cdc asking
why this is the case why it is that in
the united states of america
we have these guidance documents in
place
directing people to put mass on children
as young as two years old
when our peer nations all over the world
have said it
much much higher look our our allies are
our peer nations in in all over europe
from uk uh uh from france
uh in so many other countries have the
age up at around
11 or 12. even the world health
organization
that's much more aggressive says maybe
five enough
but to set it at two and up in the
united states reflects um
some real hubris it reflects uh really
what happens when
somebody issuing the guidance documents
doesn't spend a lot of time with
two-year-olds
but as much as anything we just want to
know what the scientific evidence is
look we know that children of that age
have a lower rate of infection we have
recent belief that they
have a tendency to spread the virus less
so i want to know
what their scientific evidence is that
we need to have children as young as two
being forced to wear a mask
the washington examiner we talked a lot
we've talked a lot about cove we also
were talking a lot about immigration and
the washington examiner
they obtained this memo from politico
politico had sent this memo out to some
of their employees
talking about immigration and said do
not call it a crisis this is what the
memo said avoid referring to the present
situation as a crisis
although we may quote others using that
language while providing context
while the sharp increase of the arrival
of unaccompanied minors is a problem for
border officials
a political challenge for the biden
administration and a dire situation for
many migrants
who make the journey it does not fit the
dictionary definition
of a crisis what is your reaction
if they think that this isn't a crisis
they need to select
a new dictionary if their dictionary
somehow on some bizarre planet
doesn't match this then maybe they
haven't been to the border and they're
looking for the wrong
definition look the fact is anyone who's
been down there as i have in recent
weeks as
so many of my colleagues have it is
nothing short of a crisis okay we were
down there we
literally saw a human body floating in
the rio grande we literally
saw women and infant children sleeping
in the dirt and we saw 4 200 children
crammed into a facility
currently designed to handle no more
than 250.
uh if that's not a crisis i don't know
what is
uh the human suffering here is is is
beyond a scale that most americans see
on any regular basis
so the real question is why are they
just deciding
to do favors for the biden
administration by distorting the truth
they've done other headlines that talk
about the economic crisis
police brutality and racism is a crisis
the climate is a crisis
but apparently not immigration senator
lee thank you so much for being on with
us have a great weekend
thank you same to you thank you